[Musique]
annie genevard bonjour bonjour donc
président par intérim de l air et député
du doubs avant de parler de votre
éventuelle entrée au gouvernement pour
reprendre la question david parlons de
la crise énergétique qui domine cette
rentrée les députés aient l'air ont
annoncé hier qu'il souhaitait une
commission denquête pour eux enquêter
sur les choix stratégiques effectués
dans le passé par la france pourquoi
même parce que si nous sommes dans cette
situation ce n'est pas seulement due à
la guerre avec l'udc en ukraine c'est
aussi dû au choix
politique que la france a fait qu'ils
manuel macro et avant lui françois
hollande ont fait en matière nucléaire
depuis dix ans on affaiblit la filière
nucléaire on ferme des réacteurs pour
satisfaire des accords politiques avec
les verts on se prive on s'est privé
d'une énergie propre d'une énergie peu
cher et on est aujourd'hui dans la plus
grande difficulté et df vend à perte son
électricité et achète l'électricité à
prix d'or c'est absolument linverse de
ce qu'il faudrait faire et là nous avons
des comptes à demander manuel mâcon qui
se défaussent sur françois hollande ça
manque singulièrement d'élégance parce
que fessionnels c'est quand même lui qui
l'affirmé et surtout nous voulons par
cette commission denquête faire des
propositions pour reconstruire au plus
vite cette filière nucléaire qui a fait
quand même la fierté de la france et la
force de la souveraineté mais en
enquêtant sur le passé on va aussi
trouver sous les présidents de droite
peut-être des choix qui n'ont pas été
toujours eu du retard par exemple sur
les énergies renouvelables qui serait
aujourd'hui précieuse oui mais elle les
énergies renouvelables soit mais on sait
très bien que ça ne suffira pas à
satisfaire la demande énergétique et les
énergies renouvelables
elles ont prospéré à leur rythme et on
peut pas en attendre non plus une
couverture complète des besoins des
français bien sûr qu'il faut développer
les énergies renouvelables
pas n'importe quel prix pas en couvrant
les terres agricoles de panneaux
photovoltaïques pas en défigurant nos
paysages avec de l'éolien
proposés par des sociétés financières
qui achètent à prix d'or l'accord des
maires non l'énergie l'énergie
alternative l'énergie
durable elle est nécessaire à développer
mais elle ne suffira pas soutenez-vous
le président qui demande aux français un
effort de sobriété dans les
comportements de tous les jours vous
savez je pense que les français n'ont
pas besoin d'être infantilisés
parce que quand on paye l'énergie plus
cher à la majorité des français que
font-ils il baisse le chauffage enfin et
ce qu'ils aient besoin de d'expliquer
aux français qu'il faut chauffer mois
ils ont le faire de même parce qu'ils ne
pourront plus assumer le coût du
chauffage par contre ces conseils ne
peuvent pas tenir lieu de politique
énergétique
il faut véritablement investir dans les
nouveaux réacteurs développés des petits
ragots réacteurs relancer à c'est prévu
mais c'était disant lutter bien sûr ça
c'est le moyen terme lutter contre les
passoires énergétiques
décarbonés les transports doublé le fret
ferroviaire il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire en matière d'énergie alors
évidemment la mesure la plus facile
c'est de dire est immédiate mais c'est
le chauffage mais les français sont pas
idiots ils n'ont pas besoin d'être
d'avoir des conseils qu'ils vont
appliquer soutenez-vous le projet de
contribution européenne sur les
opérateurs d'énergie qui ont fait
beaucoup de bénéfices solution franco
allemande ça permettrait d'éviter le
débat sur la taxe sur les super fraude
profits en france il faut se poser la
question des profits de crise
si la crise engendre des profits
considérables
il faut s'interroger sur leur
redistribution partielle
l'impôt vous savez la france est la
championne des tac je vous rappelle que
entre la france l'allemagne il ya une
différence de 150 milliards en matière
de pression fiscale donc
moi je pense que la piste de l'impôt en
plus l'impôt va aussi ce qui va à l'état
et dont on connaît la voracité pas
forcément français et pas forcément
français donc pas si on ne fait pas de
taxes je cache en fait je pense que
l'incitation et d'ailleurs on l'a vu au
total total a consenti une remise de 30
centimes d'euro sur les carburants sous
la pression du gouvernement
mais comment voulez-vous demander à edf
à qui on vienne ponctionner 8 milliards
d'euros et dont on a fragilisé les
équilibres financiers alors moi je pense
que le président de la république a
cherché à esquiver ce débat à la place
d'une taxe nationale il propose une
contribution européenne de façon à mieux
faire passer le la pilule mais il
étendra pas le débat parce que la france
est soumise est acharnée c'est quand
même une proposition d a soumis ce que
je voudrais le dire sur cette question
c'est qu'une fois de plus le
gouvernement navigue à vue puisque bruno
le maire y est opposée elisabeth bornes
n'est pas hostile donc ça va se trancher
lors du débat budgétaire ça va se
trancher lors du débat budgétaire mais
ça sera une des stars du débat budget
avec peut-être arbitrage des députés
élèves qui pèseront aussi jeu c'est
possible ce que je constate c'est que
quand même finalement ce débat le maire
bornes taxe versus contribution ça
illustre bien le caractère très
composite de la majorité des manuels
macron on l'a vu pendant cinq ans ça
éclate à nouveau dans cette affaire et
mais voilà on paie on payait aussi la
conséquence de la politique énergétique
qui a été conduite par nos dirigeants
depuis 10 ans et ça si vous voulez il
faut quand même que chacun assume assume
sa responsabilité lorsque emmanuel
macron dit moi je suis pas responsable
la décision politique qualité avait été
prise par françois hollande depuis quand
un politique ne peut pas défaire ou
interrompre un processus kahn s'est
pressé le président macro et à étaler
ses politiques de freinage du nucléaire
il avait redonné disant oui mais il
aurait pu il aurait pu faire demi tour
sur sur fessenheim parce que quand même
l' agence de sûreté nucléaire conteste
le caractère dangereux de la centrale
étaient entretenues si maintenant on a
je crois 30 réacteurs à l'arrêt c'est
parce que il ya une démobilisation
complète de la filière nucléaire sont
j'ai quand même que la réduction du
nombre de centrales est toujours dans la
loi
livrer du gaz aux allemands cet hiver en
échanges d'électricité ça c'est une
bonne politique de solidarité européenne
bon si la france
n'y perd pas de plus parce que si on
écoute emmanuel macron
nous capacités gazières sont importantes
donc il faut pas déshabiller pierre pour
habiller paul il faut aussi voir
vous allez les français sont dans une
situation très difficile et les
entreprises et les collectivités les
piscines ferment partout on est obligé
de réduire le niveau de service à la
population
quant aux entreprises elles nous
appellent au secours je ne sais pas on
va assister à une désindustrialisation
absolument considérable l'envolée des
prix de l'énergie est
la dernière entreprise qui m'a appelé et
passent de 40 mille cinq cent mille îles
on est inquiet soit facture ils ne
peuvent pas la future l'haute travail
passe au conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui les républicains voteront
t-il la réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui veut inciter à la reprise d'emploi
alors si j'ai bien lu ce qu'il va y
avoir dans cette loi
est d'ailleurs elisabeth bornes l'avait
dit lors de la déclaration de politique
générale il s'agit de prolonger
l'existant vous savez que
l'indemnisation du chômage a été réformé
et cette réforme n'a été mise en oeuvre
que en 2021 courant en 2021 donc la
première ministre a annoncé que cette
loi permettait de prolonger
cette réforme de l'indemnisation du
chômage donc prolongé l'existant je
pense que c'est totalement insuffisant
la meilleure preuve c'est que on a quand
même trois millions de demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie a et de la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre et une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui éclatent partout alors que
faut-il faire alors ça veut dire que il
faut alors il ya deux phénomènes qu'il
faut corriger ya le phénomène des refus
de cdi au fond ce qu'on voit c'est que
beaucoup de salariés refusent des cdi
pour pouvoir enchaîner des périodes de
travail et des périodes de chômage
et ça il faut pouvoir corriger c'est une
dérive du système c'est un abus de la
solidarité nationale ça met en péril les
comptes sociaux donc il faut pouvoir
corriger cela et il faut pouvoir sans
tarder former rapidement là on a un
manque de deux mineurs qui nous oblige
qui oblige certains certaines
entreprises à réduire la voilure refusé
du travail ou parfois même fermé donc
moi ce que j'attends de cette loi
travail c'est que
comme toujours les mots sont semble fort
cellule faits et les mesures soient à la
hauteur pourquoi ne pas participer au
conseil national de la refondation qui
sera lancé demain pour faire avancer ses
idées
vous savez emmanuel macron et a toujours
privilégié depuis qu'il est arrivé à
l'elysée ces grandes de ces grandes
instances et grand c grand messe
il ya eu bien sûr le grand débat pour
éteindre la colère des gilet jaune il ya
eu la convention citoyenne pour le
climat pour éteindre
là l'inquiétude et et l'hostilité de
ceux qui veulent la décroissance pour
sauver la planète
et puis il ya eu une quantité d'états
généraux de ségur de boulot de grenelle
là ce sont les dialogues de bercy voilà
donc il ya le constat il est fait on
sait tout de la situation
et c'est un constat bon je dis pas qu'il
est partagé par tous évidemment pas mais
par beaucoup donc on sait ce qu'on doit
faire on sait que
l'hôpital public doit être
débureaucratiser on sait que l'école
pech sur la transmission des savoirs
essentiels on sait que on va devoir
affronter la grande
réforme donc il faut des lois maintenant
il faut agir maintenant il faut des lois
il faut agir si vous voulez la
procrastination le fait de toujours
remettre au moyen de deux de ces grognes
ces grands rassemblements de ses grandes
loges de remettre
l'action a plus tard c'est pas possible
le parti votre parti républicain aura un
nouveau président le 3 décembre est-ce
que vous pouvez encore candidate et vous
même vous avez jusqu'au 3 octobre je
peux encore vous y réfléchissez y
écouter la réponse est imminente très
bien mais nous attendons cette réponse
mais il ya peut-être d'abord la
nécessité d'avoir une femme dans cette
compétition et puis une voix gaulliste
différentes alors clairement je pense
que ce serait à soi seul un vrai facteur
de nouveautés de renouvellement que
d'avoir une femme à la tête du mouvement
d'autre part jean connaît parfaitement
les rouages parce que j'en ai été le
secrétaire général puis la
vice-présidente et maintenant la
présidente et puis je suis je crois
avoir donné
des preuves de loyauté infaillible à ma
famille politique et d'être très engagé
avoir des convictions fortes et mais
voilà c'est une élection il ya des
candidats
très déterminé vous disiez avant l'été à
ce micro il faudrait désigner un vrais
présidentiables mais qu'ils sachent
rassembler ça sera pas le cas on n'est
pas le cas ce ne sera pas le cas c'était
dans nos habitudes si je peux dire est
dans notre dans notre adn mais voilà il
faut prendre acte du fait que le ou les
présidentiables possibles n'ont pas
souhaité prendre la présidence du parti
ils ont souhaité se placer finalement au
dessus de la mêlée et donc votre figure
arbitral toute sa légitimité tout à fait
mais je crois que ça ça implique qu'on
redéfinisse le rôle des partis aussi les
parties sont plus des incubateurs de
présidentiable ils sont autre chose ils
sont indispensables à la démocratie et
évidemment ils sont le lieu où s'élabore
une pensée poétique où se débattent des
choix où s'élaborent des stratégies ou
où se met en place un outil de conquête
électorale
et ça vous savez faire et ça ben je sais
faire comme comme un certain nombre de
mes petits camarades qui sont dans les
stades dans les starting blocks eh bien
ni genevard peut-être future candidate à
la présidence dlr merci beaucoup et
bonne journée merci christophe barbier
merci beaucoup christophe et demain
votre invité demain jeudi 8 septembre
votre vidéo sera céline calves député
des hauts de seine